so to people who believe you my hearing
aid workers
are often happy and feel fulfilled by
their work i would say that
yes this is definitely true uh it's it's
a big part of the truth
especially when we do choose to do this
job it is a job that requires a lot of
work
it's often a job that you carry out
under pressure
and often because of the motivation you
put in you you tend to push yourself
it is also a job that i think shows you
really the strength and the beautiful
side of people
on how they cope and then i'm often
amazed by by the things i see and and i
often wonder how people can go
through what they're going through and
um and so i think that makes you
think about your life and it doesn't
make you feel particularly happy
but it is also a job where you are often
not able to
fix the fundamental issues especially if
you are humanitarian
workers or working on emergency
responses and i think this
over time can become difficult to handle
it can become
frustrating and realizing that you are
you would like to fix everything and you
can't